المتظاهرون يغلقون طريقًا رئيسيًا إلى بيروت
غاضبون من الأزمة الاقتصادية المتفاقمة في لبنان
غاضبون من النخبة السياسية التي لا تفعل شيئًا في
الوقت الذي تنهار فيه البلاد
ومع الغضب يأتي اليأس
[موسيقى]
فرصة لشعب فخور للتعبير عن أحزانه
لا يمكنني الحصول على الدواء  لا يمكنني الحصول على
الحليب لابني ،
لا يمكنني الحصول على أي شيء دمرناه تمامًا
يقول الصودا الملونة
تغلبت عليها العاطفة أننا نموت يومًا بعد
يوم ،
بدأ دوري العرض في أوائل عام 2020.
نبدأ هذا لأن لبنان
انتهى ،
مثل لبنان  قلنا وداعا
لا بيروت لا لا لبنان
لا طعام ولا حفاضات ولا حليب ولا مدرسة
ولا غاز ولا بنزين لا شيء في العالم
على مدى العامين الماضيين تلاشى الاقتصاد.
فقد فقدت العملة المحلية
أكثر من 90 في المائة من تضخم قيمتها.
متفشية وفقًا
للأمم المتحدة ،
77 في المائة من الأسر ليس لديها
ما يكفي من
الطعام ، لكن السياسيين يبدون
غير
مبالين بالأزمة المشلولة بسبب الاقتتال الداخلي
بعد عرض دوري وموظفيه
يوزعون أكياسًا من الطعام
تبرع بها المستمعون لأولئك الذين اتصلوا
قبل عامين ، حصلت مارينا ناكاشيان على
ما يعادل أكثر من
800 شهرًا ، والآن تبلغ
قيمتها أكثر من 70.
في أكتوبر 2019 ،
انضم مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص
إلى انتفاضة ضد الطبقة الحاكمة
المتهمة بالفساد وعدم الكفاءة ،
ولكن اليوم بعيدًا عن الاحتجاجات الصغيرة المتفرقة ،
أصبح البقاء هادئًا هو
الأولوية القصوى الآن ، كما يقول زعيم الطلاب والناشط
كريم صفياد في أزمة اقتصادية واسعة النطاق.
غالبية الناس في الشارع
الذين كانوا في الشوارع يبحثون الآن
عن وظائف
قليلة الحد الأدنى للأجور والحد الأدنى من القدرة على
إطعام أطفالهم
في مدينة
صيدون الجنوبية ،
يقول الجزار سادهاشون إنه يبيع في غضون أسبوع ما يريد
بيعه في يوم واحد.
حكام يقصد أنهم سيحكمون هذا
البلد لمائة عام
يجب أن نكون كذلك
بينما يتشاجر السياسيون
ويموت لبنان
شيئًا فشيئًا يومًا بعد يوم.